now i know that this is going to
disappoint a lot of you guys but based
on some leaks
rumors and things that apple have said
themselves i am now confident that a
very powerful
intel base mac is coming later this year
so prepare to be surprised because this
is gonna get
interesting let's begin with some very
old leaks
that didn't really make much sense until
right now now i don't know if you
remember this but
over a year ago twitter user row game
discovered some very interesting bits of
code
within mac os beta pointing to brand new
navi 21 graphics card support coming to
the mac
and then in june right after apple
announced mac os big sur
at their wwdc event even more code was
discovered
pointing to newer navi 31 graphics
support
also coming to the mac so you might be
thinking that all of that was meant for
the 27-inch
intel-based imac that we got released in
august
but the very best graphics card option
in that imac
is the 5700xt which is actually based
on navi 10 not 21 and certainly not
31. this basically shows that apple was
planning on adding support for those
newer architectures in the future
which might seem a little bit weird
unless they're planning on releasing
another intel-based mac before the
transition
to apple silicon is completed and i
believe that's exactly what apple is
going to be doing
mostly because of this quote from last
year's wwc
event we plan to continue to support and
release new versions of mac os for intel
based macs for years to come
in fact we have some new intel based
macs in the pipeline
that we're really excited about yes tim
cook mentioned
some intel based macs and as we all know
the only one they've released so far is
the 27-inch imac
which shows that they've got at least
one more intel based mac coming in the
future and as of right now
after seeing how incredibly good apple's
very first
and weakest m1 ship has been performing
compared to intel chips
like the slaughterfest that happened in
one of our latest laptop comparisons
everybody already knows that they should
avoid intel
on the consumer level max because apple
silicon
is just too good however there is still
one mac that could potentially fit the
bill
for getting an intel based chip and that
is of course
the mac pro so let me explain why the
current 2019 mac pro is now the only mac
that's available with an intel xeon
champ and that chip is extremely
important for specific workflows like
high-end
mathematical and scientific computation
since xeon chips are fine-tuned to run
complex tasks with very wide bit depths
and of course the ecc ram is very
desirable
for those workflows as well and it's
exclusive
to high-end machines like the mac pro on
top of that
it supports up to 1.5 terabytes of ram
which is absolutely overkill for 99 of
the people out
there but there are very specific
workflows
that can actually utilize all of it and
there are huge corporations
that will pay thousands upon thousands
of dollars
for a machine like the mac pro and if
you really think about it it would be a
shame
if apple spent years on research and
development as well as
tons of resources on all of the custom
tooling
and custom components in the 2019 mac
pro
just to completely ditch all of that
when the new apple silicon mac pro is
released
and we know for sure that the new apple
silicon mac pro is not going to be using
the same cheese grater chassis because
it's overkill
with the huge motherboard and everything
else and by simply looking at the new
24-inch imac
we know that apple wants to go smaller
with their new apple silicon max
so what i'm trying to say is that it
totally makes sense for apple
to reuse the current mac pro's design
for
at least one more intel based mac pro
refresh
and we've actually got quite a few leaks
and rumors to support this conclusion
a couple of months back mark german from
bloomberg a very reliable apple analyst
claimed that apple was working on two
mac pro
high-end desktop machines he even
mentioned that one of them will be a
refreshed model
that will reuse the same chassis and
that will continue to use
intel processors which is what this
video is all
about and of course there will be a
second version
that will use apple's own chips and be
less than half the size of the current
mac pro
so based on that and everything else
that i've already mentioned
the intel based mac pro is definitely
happening
and here's why i think it's gonna get
released this december
first off apple's super high-end
machines like the 2013 mac pro
the 2017 imac pro and the 2019 mac pro
were always released in december because
it's targeted towards huge businesses
who need to get tax write-offs before
the end of the year
by investing their extra profits and the
reason i think that it's coming this
december and not
next year is because i believe that's
when the apple silicon mac pro is gonna
get released
right at the end of their two-year
timeline for the transition
but the even more telling reason is
because of this massive leak
that recently showed up an apple mac pro
exclusive
amd radeon pro w6900x gpu
has randomly popped up on geekbench with
the highest metal score
ever seen on any mac in this test even
beating out the regular
6900 xt which this x card is based on
now there are some people that say that
this is a fake result
that's actually using a hackintosh
system because
it's noted as using an intel core
processor
but i actually think that it's legit and
here's why
that i9 core chip is using intel's
latest cascade lake architecture
but since the latest xeons haven't yet
made it onto store shelves
i think that geekbench didn't recognize
the new xeon chip
so it defaulted to that 12 core chip
that it does recognize
and on top of that if it actually was a
hackintosh with a regular 6900 xt
graphics card
how would it be able to get a score
that's quite a bit higher
the test result clearly shows a w6900x
which can only happen if support for
that card is already built into macos
which we saw with those previous leaks
within mac os beta code
and the wx cards use apple's custom mpx
slot
which can't be put into a hackintosh so
this is likely a legit
leaked benchmark result and just a
couple of weeks ago
support for this new navi 21 generation
of amd gpus
was finally added to mac os showing that
apple is working on the software
for these new cards and likely for this
brand new
w6900x for the mac pro and if you're
wondering how it's able to get a higher
score
than the other 6900 xt it's likely
because it'll be coming
with 32 gigabytes of vram instead of the
regular cards
16 and we know this because apple's
w5700
xt in the mac pro has 16 gigs of vram
compared to only eight on every other
5700 xd card on the market
and going even further i have two very
good reasons for why
this new intel based mac pro is gonna
get released
this december first off amd's new 6000
series desktop gpus
like the 6900xt are already on the
market
so if apple waited even longer to
release a mac pro
with the w6900x it wouldn't feel as
fresh
or powerful anymore and second intel
finally launched their new 3rd gen xeons
last month
based on the new 10 nanometer ice lake
architecture
which should give it some pretty good
advantages that apple would definitely
want
in their refresh mac pro but this
creates a huge
problem these new xeon chips require a
brand
new socket which also requires a brand
new
motherboard this means that apple can't
simply refresh the same listing page
for the current mac pro and add those
new intel chips
they literally have to redesign the
motherboard to add
the new socket which means that it needs
to have a new part number
which in turn means that it's likely
going to be named the 2021
mac pro so yeah if you take all of the
information
from this video everything points to
apple releasing a new
intel based mac pro this december based
on
the current cheese grater chassis so
there you guys go
that was all of my reasoning for why
we're getting a new intel based mac pro
this year
and if you totally disagree with me
comment your thoughts
down below but if you enjoyed it click
that circle above to subscribe
check out one of those two videos right
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you
in the next video
[Music]